we were all just performing at UCB
theater as citizens for gays here in New
York and now Paul and I have known each
other for about ten years and had done a
lot of improvising and sketch shows
together and the Aziz was doing stand-up
and so we were all kind of he knew who
we were and we knew who he was and it
was just sort of this mutual admiration
society and as he started doing the show
every week called crash-test and it was
like a stand-up show and he kind of
wanted people to co-host it with him so
the first week he asked me and and we we
did a sketch on stage called shutter
bugs which was about we basically had I
had all these kids headshots
different don't ask why and I had all
these headshots of little kids and we
did this bit on stage where we were like
headshot photographers and we basically
just criticized these headshots of these
adorable little kids and just like rip
these kids apart and then that sort of
created the sketch that we eventually
did called shudder bugs where we sort of
changed it so we became talent agents
for little kids so that's how kind of we
met like just doing bits on stage and
doing videos and then he and Paul
co-hosted in subsequent weeks and they
did a video and a bit on stage about
kind of making fun of shitty magicians
and stuff and they did this bit called
illusion aiders which is vaguely
inspired by Criss Angel and and so
that's sort of where you know to kind of
popular sketches of ours came from just
kind of doing bits on stage maybe you
see be really
when people even talk about like those
others were actually super flattered to
even be compared to any of them I mean
we have a lot of fun doing what we're
doing and try to do really funny stuff
but yeah I mean they're amazing sketch
groups in the pantheon of sketch history
and yeah I mean that's always like
really flattering to be compared to any
of those guys we just want to like we
just want to keep doing our thing and
and and we really don't care about
anything else but just like making funny
stuff you know like we don't worry about
what's coming up down the road or
anything like that and we tried you know
the great thing about like the the
comedy world right now is that um
there's just like a really good feel
like it's a really good time for comedy
you know there's just a lot of cool
stuff going on and people are doing you
know especially in New York for sure
like we're just doing like really smart
different funny stuff and you know we're
glad to be in the mix and and what's
cool about it is that there's also like
this sort of really supportive community
and like no one ever shits on anybody
else you know you don't ever hear people
like just attacking other people it's
just kind of a cool community right now
there seems to be like a lot of just
admiration for different people doing
different stuff whether it's stand-up or
sketch or improv or whatever like just
seems to be like a really supportive
cool thing and I mean for example you
know we were able to get some guys from
SNL to do some bits in our show like
Andy Samberg and Fred Armisen and Bill
Hader and you know they that we've known
those guys for a while and but they just
really liked the show and we were like
but you guys are already on a really
great show it's a very famous sketch
comedy show you know and there's like
yeah but it'd be fun to do your show you
know so that's just kind of cool there's
no like you know no one's knowing fights
or whatever it's just kind of cool to
pop up and other people's projects
you